fun tip reapply if you want no do it is
there like an intro I'm Dan levy and
these are my first up I am a writer so
it's integral that I have something to
write on and this is my macbook and it's
real thin which means I can store it
quickly or just grab it and go which I
mean I'm not being chased often so I
don't really need to grab and go but
it's thin and like I use final draft
which is a pretty standard screenwriting
software but I also use notes I just got
into like dictation on the phone on the
computer and the phone so now I just
like say things and it types for me hi
I'm from 1965 speaking of writing
apparatus my next item is my notebook if
you are a writer this is an essential I
think you need your technology but you
also need something very practical to
just nothing like pen on paper you know
what I mean I keep this by the bed
because oftentimes when I'm falling
asleep I never fall asleep I'm an
insomniac I will come up with ideas as
I'm sort of drifting off and I need
something quick to jot the notes down so
oftentimes there's like a pen in here
and a lot of scratch and then I'll wake
up in the morning and not be able to
read any of it because oftentimes I
write in the dark so if you are going to
take notes in the night turn the light
on that's the first step and this
particular notebook has a lot of
sentimental value to me because it was a
prop in my store on my show and my show
is now finished so this means a lot
there's about 10 pages in here of top
secret ideas let's see if they go
anywhere we'll do a follow-up in a year
and see what happens nice leather-bound
notebook if you are a writer invest in
one
[Music]
next essential the diptych Tokyo candle
now this is gonna be a weird brag this
candle is only available in Tokyo so
whenever I like to travel I try to find
things that are unique to the place and
it's hard to bring back delicious food
from Japan so this is always a very
special gift that I will bring back for
myself and some friends it also happens
to be my favorite scent out of this
collection of candles so I try to
collect them I think it's pretty special
I think if you know anyone in Japan or
if you ever visit Japan a worthwhile
investment a great gift and always
impresses at a dinner party when you
show up with something that nobody else
has let's open it up now I am NOT a
perfumer so I'm gonna give you a
description of this smell based on my
college dropout education okay it's
clean smells like fresh laundry
I think there's lavender in there
probably not it basically smells like
you've archived clean human you know
what I mean
I think for me my favorite smells are
that of just hygiene general hygiene and
this candle when lit in your home makes
you smell clean
[Music]
speaking of being clean my next item
this is a travel mist and for those of
you that aren't plagued with a fear of
germs and getting sick skip past this
item but this is essentially a general
disinfectant for airplanes I'm pretty
sure that you can use this everywhere
but they seem to be making money off of
this being specific to an airline so
great this was sent to me a long time
ago and I have used it religiously ever
since simple spray it says shake well so
I will and basically once you get to
your seat in the airplane or you know if
you don't like the person sitting beside
you just everywhere and it apparently
disinfects not just the space but the
air as well so I've just told you all of
deep dark secret about myself
but there are a lot of people who are
into airplane hygiene fun tip reapply if
you want next essential
these are matchstick incense they are
perfect for a bathroom a bedroom they're
perfect to throw into a piece of luggage
if you travel a lot again I found these
in Japan I go there often so it's
another little secret surprise and
essentially you take them out
light it up let it burn it comes with
like a little disc I don't have it here
but the actual kit comes like a little
disc so then you blow it out and it's a
delicious Japanese Cypress scent and if
you're having guests over I often like
to put them by the toilet in case of any
kind of emergency let the guests feel
comfortable in times of need but it is a
delightful smell and they last for 10
minutes
and sometimes if you're traveling and
you are staying at an Airbnb that's
really smelly and you want to make it
smell just too smelly but like good
Meli witchcraft very worthwhile
affordable and for those of you that
enjoy the incense experience it is a
delicious flavor Japanese Cypress they
come in a bunch of different flavors
[ __ ] hibi they do good they do good work
essential Joan Didion slouching towards
Bethlehem my favorite of all of her
books and I include this because I feel
like while this might be my favorite it
is important for everyone to have a book
in their essentials list and for me as a
writer she is someone that inspires me a
lot she's able to articulate her life
and observances and very thoughtful and
interesting and left-of-center ways so I
always like to have one of the books
around because in times of need I will
turn to it for inspiration and
motivation so books essentials next
essential okay this is a bit of a
splurge but to me I feel like this
essential covers a lot of faces so if
you want to splurge this is a great
investment this is a pair of prada
slacks they are a technical fabric slim
fit pant and I got them not really
thinking anything of it put them on and
not only are they incredibly flattering
they've certainly given me an ass and I
normally just have a back that splits
into legs
so thank you to these pants for doing
that but also they are an amazing dress
pant but they're also a great everyday
pant and to me that's a twofer so you're
buying a pant that covers a lot of bases
you can wear them with a blazer and a
shirt and a tie and some great shoes out
for a night on the town you can wear
them with some converse and a t-shirt
like I like to do they come in like I
think this is a navy sorry I think these
are just two shades of black ones just a
little bit lighter you don't need to do
what I did and buy to the same pair but
pick one and I promise you not only will
you live in them but you will be
thanking me when you ever run into a
situation where you have to go from day
to night very quickly great great great
investment if you can
swing it
second investment item in the essentials
list these are a loafer made by the way
they these are my favorite they're in a
brown sort of embossed crock I believe
and the back goes down so you can wear
them really casually or sort of keep the
back up and wear them as a traditional
loafer I always like to sort of cover
all my bases I can wear these dress-up I
can wear them dress down I can wear them
shorts and a shirt if I'm on vacation
they can just you know gets thrown into
a bag and they're a nice alternative to
a sandal they're a nice alternative to
like a chuck and they just you know they
sort of make you look like you know what
you're doing so for those of us that
don't know what we're doing these are a
great investment to trick people into
believing the opposite next essential is
my dog which at this point I guess is
sort of would we call him a life partner
I don't know best friend confidant he
has been around for all six seasons of
my show and I feel like the great thing
about he's a rescue you're going to get
a pet I highly encourage you to rescue
one many sites that you can go to to
rescue animals and he's a dachshund and
a Corgi mix which I believe is the
Queen's breed I think the Queen actually
originated the Dorji and then speaking
of a baller move when her last dog died
she did not read it again because she
doesn't want anyone else to have her
breed of dog after she dies that is
absolute gossip but something that I
believed to be true this little guy
changed my life so this is read Redmond
is his full name and he's pretty great
so he is one of my essentials and
hopefully will be until he's 900 years
old I would like to die long before him
[Music]
okay so this is arguably going to be the
most divisive essential on my essentials
list when I am in dark times often times
I will turn to bubbles eating now people
at home are probably saying Dan you're
disgusting I'm changing the channel
that's fair a lot of people agree with
you I don't know I can't I don't know
what to say I always turn to a bubble
tea when I need one the most now these
are not my flavors but they are for
somebody I prefer a traditional black
milk tea with a normal tapioca pearl and
a pearl is what button bubble tea
drinkers refer to as the bubbles at the
bottom of the glass you'll get to know
they'll vocabulary the more you wade
into the waters of bubble tea land I'm
gonna try this one this seems to have
like an apricot pearl which scares me a
bit I'm not gonna lie oh absolutely not
nope oh they explode okay don't get the
ones that explode in your mouth that has
some sort of jam inside that just burst
in my mouth and I'm feeling light-headed
I would recommend a black milk tea with
the traditional tapioca pearl I guess I
like poke do we have to amend this I
guess so we're making a quick amendment
to that last thing I have since learned
that boba and bubble are two different
things
bubble is what I was drinking I do not
love bubble tea
I like boba tea boba are the tapioca
pearls so that's the latest with me and
you know I yes a black milk boba tea no
offense to bubble tea drinkers
I am a boba tea drinker I've now learned
so baba tapioca pearls bubbles pop in
your mouth okay I like a boba tea
last essential I can't do the like Mac
Wireless any er things they always pop
out I honestly don't know whose ears are
built for those little things because I
take one step and those things are
flying out of my ears so these are the
Bose wireless in-ear headphones they
sort of have a wire they can there's
like something that like makes them
stick in your ear it's like a more
ergonomic thing you can really find them
anywhere but the Bose are my favorites
wear them every single day I walk a lot
i podcast a lot I like to listen to
everything on my trips what's on my
playlist right now I was like last night
I was really enjoying like a Fleetwood
Mac radio a lot of your parents favorite
hits are coming up on that
like the Eagles a Steely Dan I just got
back to California so I'm feeling like
some nice California anthems you know
in-ear wireless headphones a nice
alternative to what comes with your
phone and the case is a lot bigger and
charges itself so you won't necessarily
lose that little pill case that those
the other ones come in well that was it
these are my essentials hope you enjoyed
hope you live laughs and loved with me
see you next time
[Music]